Google claims it has reached a key
milestone using a quantum computer to
complete a task that a classical
computer couldn't manage achieving what
they call quantum supremacy this would
be the first time that a quantum
computer has definitively beaten the
best conventional computer it's
something that physicists have been
trying to do for years although not
everyone is convinced that a normal
computer would find this particular task
impossible it certainly seems like the
quantum processor solves it faster the
task is a calculation that is not very
useful it was designed just to
demonstrate the quantum supremacy and
was made to be especially difficult for
normal computers to handle Google's
quantum computer is called Sycamore it
has just 53 qubits quantum versions of
the bits that encode information and a
computer these behave completely
differently to regular bits and very
hard to manipulate but in theory they
should allow the computer to carry out
certain kinds of calculations way faster
than a classical machine the calculation
in this test was to figure out the
probability distribution of all the
possible outcomes from a quantum random
number generator because the generator
creates random numbers using quantum
operations simulating this distribution
on a classical computer is extremely
tough but Google's machine only needed
to set herself up like the generator and
then run those operations a bunch of
times
Sycamore produced an answer in just
three minutes and twenty seconds but
proving quantum supremacy means facing
off against classical competition for
that research has borrowed the
supercomputing might of the summit
supercomputer at Oak Ridge National
Laboratory in Tennessee by breaking up
the problem into smaller chunks and then
extrapolating they estimate that summit
would take 10,000 years to finish the
same calculation if true this means that
a quantum computer can do something that
is in practice
impossible on a classical machine
quantum super embassy but not everyone
agrees
IBM is released a paper claiming that
the summit supercomputer could actually
complete the task in just two-and-a-half
days by using a slightly different
technique scientists will now scrutinize
both camps calculations but even if IBM
is right it's still significant the
sycamore is so much faster than the
supercomputer it's the first time that
this kind of quantum speed-up has ever
been shown it wouldn't be the standard
definition of quantum supremacy but
physicists think it's a big deal and
although we're still decades from
harnessing the full potential quantum
computers and maybe years from doing
anything particularly useful at all this
achievement tells us that quantum
computing is edging ever closer to those
goals
you
[Music]